- [Girl] I hear, that
they're gonna make alcohol
completely legal in Denver.
- [Brunette] No way.
And like sell it in Seven11 like weed?
- Yep.
- That's crazy.
- No, I read it in Slate.
- Is that the guy?
- [Red Head] Yeah.
- Looks scary.
- No, if you just act
cool, then he'll act cool.
- Hey, you Allison?
- Yeah.
- Alright.
Here's a six-pack.
- That's only three bottles.
- I said here's your six-pack.
- [Red Head] Run, run!
- So, what brings you in
for an alcohol prescription?
- I've just been feeling
like, a little anxious,
and I've been having
some trouble sleeping.
- Oh, this'll definitely help.
Have you medicated before?
- Drink it right?
- You can drink it, you
could like, guzzle it.
You could like, get on your hands and put
it in your mouth, you could do it in like,
a lot of little glasses.
You could just kind of
like, figure out what
works for your body.
- Okay, great.
- Do you have your license?
- Yeah, I do.
- [Doctor] Okay, I trust you.
Well, you're good to go.
- Thank you.
- Take care of yourself.
- Hey, do you have an alcohol card?
- Hey, I heard you got a card.
- Hey.
I'm having a party this weekend.
Could you give me a little help?
- Sure.
So I just fill this out,
and then I go in and
they'll give me whatever I want?
- Yup.
- Do they take credit cards?
- Nope. There's an ATM machine with
a six dollar surcharge.
- Woof!
- And no cell phones!
- By God.
Ma'am.
- Oh, oh I have a prescription.
- Doesn't matter, you can't have this much
in public, this is intent to distribute.
Let's go.
- But, I'm a good person.
- Why don't you just smoke
weed like everyone else?
It's healthier.